this video is brought to you by
scentbird
[Music]
what's up guys michael here to talk
about a group of individuals responsible
for making sure that society is just and
fair you have my sword
and you have my bow
and my axe no not those guys we're
talking about the supreme court one of
the three co-equal branches of
government it was created to provide
checks and balances on the others but as
the recent leak of the current court's
decision regarding roe v wade hit the
news you might have wondered wasn't this
already decided if not are all of our
laws subject to change and how did nine
unelected folks end up with our fates in
their very old hands let's find out in
this wisecrack edition on the supreme
court what went wrong but before we get
into it i want to tell you about this
video's sponsor scentbird scentbird is a
fragrant subscription service that helps
you discover your personal style and
grow your fragrance collection every
month you'll receive a 30-day supply of
your new scent of your choice this month
i tried mason 21gs sage supreme and i
love the fresh green woody notes it
reminds me of summers growing up in
tennessee when i would go see movies
with my friends or just hang out with my
family i also tried the scent book by
commodity which has notes of bergamo
eucalyptus and sandalwood like its name
suggests this scent really feels like
curling up with a good book scentbird's
wide selection includes both luxury
brands and cool indie brands like gucci
confessions of a rebel heretic and
versace if you're not sure where to
start sun bird can point you in the
right direction with help from a handy
online quiz scentbird takes the risk of
investing in a whole bottle of fragrance
right away which can be a pretty pricey
mistake if you wind up regretting your
choice instead you can get a month-long
test drive or if you like to mix up your
sense with your mood or with the seasons
senford is a great way to build a
library of fragrances for every
collection send bird subscriptions are
just 17 a month and if you're in the us
or canada and want to get 55 off your
first month of scentbird click the link
below or go to scentbird.com and enter
codewisecrack55 at checkout thanks again
to scentbird for partnering with us on
this video and don't miss the link in
the description and now back to the show
let's start in the 18th century when the
drafters of the constitution called for
the creation of the supreme court as a
means of balancing out the power of the
president and congress the document
establishes three important things about
the court first it gives it ultimate
judicial power while allowing congress
to establish other lower courts as it
saw fit side note it doesn't actually
explicitly say what judicial power means
basically leaving congress to eat prey
and love on that minor issue secondly it
states that judges on these courts shall
hold their office during good behavior
this has been interpreted to mean that
supreme court justices are appointed for
life and don't have to leave unless they
croak retire to florida or do something
shifty like treason or bribery lastly it
says the judges pay can't be decreased
while they're on the bench to ensure
they aren't being swayed by politicians
who could retaliate against court
decisions by docking their pay and
that's essentially what the founders had
to say about it it was up to congress to
use this blueprint and figure out what
the heck a supreme court was anyway now
believe it or not the court was intended
to be an apolitical body interpreting
the law through the frame of the
constitution and not any partisan set of
beliefs seriously that's not a bit
that's really what it was supposed to be
the constitution was also really vague
on details regarding the establishment
of federal courts outside of scotus this
may have been on purpose as law
professors richard w garnett and david a
strauss put it to some people in the
united states at that time the federal
government seemed almost like a foreign
government those people's main loyalty
was to their states as a result a
network of federal courts with elite
judges hand-picked by the president
legislating in far-flung states amounted
to allowing the foreign federal
government to get its tentacles into
every corner of the nation
so the issue was delicate on the one
hand who can blame people for being
worried that a bunch of hoity-toity
elites with no ties to their communities
can make decisions for them on the other
hand some of the framers were concerned
that leaving too much power to state
courts meant that hostile states could
undermine the laws of the land thus
congress determined that state courts
could get a fairly wide berth in
figuring out local laws for themselves
at the same time they acknowledged that
the supreme court established the
supreme laws of the land and would have
the power to intervene if a state court
made an unconstitutional ruling now none
of this would be the final say on what
scotus became because and i cannot
stress this enough very little about the
supreme court is in our actual
constitution and early congress had a
lot to figure out
like the makeup of the court including
the number of justices and so on
consequently the court's
responsibilities and jurisdictions have
changed multiple times since its
inception so what has been the function
of the supreme court in america and how
has that function changed and has the
institution over time become too
powerful to figure that out let's look
at one of the most pivotal moments for
the court which occurred in its
tentative early days a paradigm-changing
supreme court decision was reached under
chief justice john marshall who had been
appointed during some characteristically
petty theatrics between outgoing
president john adams and his nemesis
thomas jefferson after jefferson
defeated adams the lame-duck president's
congress passed the judiciary act of
1801 which expanded the number of
federal courts and judges adams
immediately used this new law to appoint
a bunch of midnight judges who
unsurprisingly favored him but there
wasn't enough time to formally carry out
all these appointments before adams left
office those appointees not officially
commissioned were in jefferson's eyes
rendered null and void one snubbed
appointee was would be dc justice of the
peace william marbury he took the issue
to marshall's supreme court which found
that indeed marbury had a right to the
job but marshall wasn't sure if it was
really the supreme court's place to make
this ruling to tldr this legalese the
court decided that for the most part it
did not have original jurisdiction
meaning it couldn't rule on a case for
the first time but it did have appellate
jurisdiction
that is the authority to rule on a case
on appeal so while marbury was correct
about his right to the job scotus did
not have jurisdiction to make that call
at least not until it reached the appeal
stage now it might sound like the
supreme court had ruled to limit its
power but what it really did was
establish the incredibly important
concept of judicial review the power of
the court to look at decisions made by
the other branches of the government and
other courts and determine whether or
not they are constitutional their ruling
made it official that the constitution
wasn't just a set of guidelines but was
actually the ultimate law of the land
and it was up to the supreme court to
decide what it meant and if daddy
government was using it right this seems
to be in line with what several of the
framers believed including alexander
hamilton and james madison in theory
this all means that the court is
non-partisan and exists solely to make
sure everyone's constitutional rights
are granted that sounds great and
non-controversial but when you tie your
decision making to an unchanging
document you sort of set yourself up to
be the voice of a certain status quo
which is pretty much what scotus has
been since its early days what's more as
scholars lawrence baum and neil devins
argue in their study of outside
influence over the court's decisions the
supreme court is disincentivized for
making bold rulings that might be
controversial specifically because it
doesn't have any ability to actually
carry out its own decisions there is no
supreme court police force except for
the buff ghost of ruth bader ginsburg so
today we're going to be working all the
major muscle groups at the bottom we've
got the abs games turkish
chicken wings
and critical thinking and there's no
team of supervising bureaucrats to
ensure that these rulings are actually
enacted thus the fear of backlash
against an unpopular opinion has always
loomed large as the researchers
explained this can often lead to
justices making narrower rulings in
order to avoid too much controversy the
result has been that the court is a
relatively conservative body not in a
sense of republican versus democrat but
in terms of change versus status quo as
kiyonga yamada taylor writes for the new
yorker as the branch of government that
is least accountable to the american
public the supreme court has tended for
most of its history toward a fundamental
conservatism siding with tradition over
more expansive visions of human rights
this makes sense because again they're
applying an increasingly old document to
any given contemporary scenario this was
certainly the case when it came to
slavery which was deemed a question best
left to the states in 1857 when the
court ruled that enslaved people were
property rather than citizens the
majority of judges were slave owners
their take wasn't an aberration while
slavery isn't explicitly mentioned in
the constitution it did specifically
protect the importing of slaves up until
1808 and the supreme court openly
perpetuated the idea of enslaved people
as protected property even striking down
a pennsylvania law that banned using
violence to collect escaped slaves as
erwin chemerinsky writes in his book the
case against the supreme court at every
opportunity until the civil war the
supreme court acted to protect the
rights of slave owners and denied all
rights to those who were enslaved that's
70 years of going to bed for guys like
this he is a rambunctious sword
you might be thinking that was a long
time ago things are way better now and
yes the court no longer sanctions
slavery but it did take a whole civil
war to get there and obviously ending
slavery didn't end racism and chamrinsky
notes that an important part of the
story is that the court did nothing to
advance racial equality for almost 90
years after the civil war and instead
used its power and influence to limit
the protections of the post-civil war
amendments a prime example of this was
the separate but equal decision under
plessy v ferguson that facilitated
segregation to devastating effects on
the black community and the court siding
with say plantation owners over enslaved
people wasn't a historical aberration
it's illustrative of a larger tendency
in cases where business or corporate
interests clash with those of the common
man the court has historically sided
with those in power this was illustrated
acutely during the gilded age from about
1890 to the 1930s the court embraced the
laissez-faire social darwinism that
dominated political thought at the time
they declared freedom of contract the
freedom to independently negotiate your
own business contract a constitutional
right which allowed them to strike down
tons of laws that would have protected
workers and consumers from big
corporations the thinking was if you
were an employer and your state passed a
minimum wage law that was an
infringement on your right to set your
own employment terms they struck down
over 200 federal state and local
economic regulations to protect the
sacred right of powerful corporations
the court also took huge steps to limit
federal power to protect the most
vulnerable for example they decided that
a federal ban on interstate shipment of
goods produced by child labor was
unconstitutional because that should be
left up to the states at the time states
that wanted to ban child labor risked
losing their competitive business
advantages to states that engaged in it
economic pressure those kept child labor
alive and well and the country saw
millions of children working in deadly
conditions for decades now they just
have to go to school for deadly
conditions we're not going to put that
in the video but it's and it's dark and
it's true so you know what i dare you
editor put it in there speak truth to
power note that just a decade earlier
the court had ruled that interstate
shipment of lottery tickets could be
banned by the federal government but hey
protecting the nation from out-of-state
lottery tickets but not from child labor
seems totally normal and reasonable
again what we're seeing in this time
period is a general reluctance to
protect vulnerable people from
government or corporate power it's easy
now to look back and lament the way the
supreme court functioned pre-civil war
or in the gilded age but it's worth more
closely examining what happened under
the court in its more progressive eras
of history take chief justice earl
warren's court often considered the last
one to truly represent the interests of
the common man earlier courts weren't
known for expanding civil rights and
liberties but warren was openly
committed to social justice what's more
he was likable and persuasive which led
to even some of the most controversial
cases that came across scotus's desk
reaching unanimous or near unanimous
decisions from the justices which is
basically unheard of today for such
divisive cases brown v board of
education the landmark decision which
reversed the separate but equal doctrine
was decided unanimously this is directly
because of warren's influence according
to another justice's autobiography had
the supreme court ruled in 1952 when the
case was initially argued and before
warren joined the court
there would have been a 5-4 vote to
uphold segregation what in the actual
[ __ ]
what in the actual
then there was gideon v wainwright which
found that everyone has the right to
legal counsel in a criminal case and
loving v virginia which ruled that laws
banning interracial marriage were
unconstitutional these decisions helped
create a constitutional precedent that
allowed congress to pass other important
pieces of legislation like the civil
rights act of 1964 and the voting rights
act of 1965 but not everyone was happy
with this progress especially the
definitely not a crook richard nixon
nixon maintained a 30-year beef with
earl warren who would refuse to endorse
him earlier in his political career so
when nixon became president he wanted to
tear down everything that warren had
built and due to some squabbling that
foreshadowed barack obama's nomination
of merrick garland being squashed nixon
was able to fill four seats over the
course of his short presidency his goal
he said was to appoint
strict constructionists these guys would
be interpreting the law not making the
law they would see themselves as
caretakers of the constitution and
servants of the people not super
legislators with a free hand to impose
their political and social viewpoints at
first glance this sounds relatively
apolitical but it was actually the first
glimmer of an important philosophy that
would change the way the supreme court
functioned and nixon's strict
constructionist judges were expected to
roll back some of the warren court's
broad constructionist decisions to
expand human rights that's why things
like abortion or same-sex marriage
aren't ruled expressly legal by the
supreme court but instead use
constitutional reasoning like the equal
protection clause and the right to
privacy this is also what makes any
rights not expressly delineated in the
constitution so tenuous even if they're
popular with citizens and while nixon's
appointee chief justice burger did not
roll back the warren court's decisions
on mass as expected his appointment
cemented an ideological shift in the
court and went from expanding civil
liberties to seeing such expansions of
rights as outside of the purview of the
constitution like its earlier iterations
this new court regularly ruled in favor
of corporate and institutional interest
against regular citizens today the
supreme court has several justices who
follow strict constructionism
specifically what is called textualism
which holds that the constitution should
be interpreted the way your average
person in 1787 would have interpreted it
how does that account for say the rise
of global capitalism or the invention of
the ak-47 or the rise of the internet
you might be wondering it doesn't really
but surely you must be wondering what to
make of those few exciting supreme court
cases you learned about in high school
which takes us back to the warren court
because it evokes a more romantic vision
of the institution and yet even some of
its most groundbreaking decisions look
kind of mealy-mouthed in retrospect take
brown v board which ended legal
government-mandated segregation surely
we're not going to critique this ruling
right well
in reality while the warren court struck
down lots of individual cases brought to
them about segregation in courtrooms on
buses on golf courses and restaurants
and so on they never wrote an opinion
that said state governments actually had
to do anything to actively end
segregation or prevent it from happening
quite the opposite in fact as robert l
carter wrote in the michigan law review
in 1968 the court ruled that a state is
under no affirmative obligation to enact
anti-discrimination legislation and that
such laws may be repealed but the court
added the precautionary caveat that if
in the process of repeal the state tips
the political balance in favor of racial
discrimination it violates the 14th
amendment so a state not only didn't
have to put any laws in place to end
discrimination but they also were within
their rights to repeal
anti-discrimination legislation as long
as they didn't do an oopsie and tip the
scales towards intentional
discrimination which is totally a very
easy and objective thing to measure and
prevent thus i'm sure you'll be shocked
to hear that virtually no school
desegregation actually happened for
years after brown it wasn't until the
civil rights act of 1964 that any
meaningful progress was made in
desegregation and that was limited
mostly to cities in the south in san
antonio independent school district v
rodriguez scotus even went so far as to
rule that inequalities in school funding
aren't illegal because get this the
right to equal education
isn't in the constitution that's right
scotus ruled that it's fine for schools
to be both separate and unequal as long
as the segregation isn't mandated by the
government and in the 50 years since
brown the supreme court has made america
segregation and inequality problems even
worse like the 1991 decision in which
the oklahoma city school board ceased
busing black students to white schools
as a desegregation effort because
schools had become less segregated
unsurprisingly when the busing ended the
schools became segregated again and
while there's plenty wrong with buzzing
scotus ruled schools don't have to be
equal in terms of funding and you can
probably guess whose schools weren't
being funded still the court ruled that
federal acts like bussing were only
meant as a temporary measure to remedy
past discrimination so because black
students have been given their rights
for the past 13 years the supreme court
assumed that the racial problem at the
root had been fixed what this really
meant was that schools stopped being
segregated by law but remained
effectively segregated by where people
lived and because it was fine for
schools to be unequal black and latino
students suffered overall if you look at
the supreme court over the past 50 years
you can see how a general passivity
towards granting rights has implicitly
stripped many of those rights away for
many americans take the time in 2011
when a class action lawsuit against
walmart was filed on behalf of 1.5
million women arguing that they were
paid less than and had to wait longer
for promotions than men institutionally
there was no application process for
management and employees were pan-picked
unsurprisingly this resulted in pay
raises and promotions being
disproportionately given to men and
while on three occasions the u.s court
of appeals for the ninth circuit upheld
that these women should be certified as
a class scotus ruled that there were
just too many of them to have enough in
common to justify a class
suit if they wanted to come after
walmart they should do it individually
instead as adam cohen points out in his
book supreme injustice the whole point
of a class-action lawsuit is that
individuals can collectively share
claims and show ongoing patterns of
wrongdoing without forking out their
life savings for a lawyer it is nearly
impossible for one person to show that
they have individually been
discriminated against whereas a large
representative group demonstrates a
pattern what appears to be a neutral
decision ends up being a huge loss for
average walmart workers and a huge win
for a massive corporation according to
studies the current roberts court has
been the most business friendly in
nearly a century and it's not due to
party politics liberal and conservative
judges alike seem to be able to agree on
corporate rights meanwhile decisions
that pit everyday americans against big
corporations and powerful institutions
like the police and prisons leave us
with little recourse to seek justice for
individuals because in the eyes of the
supreme court the constitution is fair
it take the decision in citizens united
via fbc which said that corporations had
the same rights as individuals to donate
money to political candidates in the
decades that followed wealthy donors and
super pacs of every political persuasion
have spent over three billion dollars to
sway elections toward candidates that
will protect their interests while
hypothetically everyone has the right to
donate to their candidates of choice we
sadly don't have the right to the type
of money that pacs have access to thus
the decision inherently favors one group
of people the mega wealthy this decision
isn't too surprising when you consider
that 70 of supreme court justices in the
past 50 years have been ivy league
graduates as sociologist g william
domhoff writes in his book who rules
america there is both a funneling and
homogenizing effect from these schools
this effect he says plays out in terms
of social networks cultural social
capital and a feeling of being part of
the in-group scholars baum and devons
take this further arguing that supreme
court justice's demographics have
material effects on how they rule they
write supreme court justices care more
about elite audiences than they do about
the mass public as they note like others
supreme court justices want most to be
liked and respected by people to whom
they are personally close and people
with whom they identify for the justices
those people are overwhelmingly part of
elite groups and in a system set up for
checks and balances between the three
branches of government many argue that
scotus wields disproportionate power
including power over the will of the
people since they're able to make wildly
unpopular decisions that don't reflect
the majority opinions of the american
public there's over 300 million of us
and nine of them according to mickey
edwards a former eight-term member of
congress and chairman of the house
republican policy committee the supreme
court is theoretically and
constitutionally separate and
independent but in reality the
separateness is a bit fuzzy that's
because even in this age of hyper
partisanship there is at least one
important area in which democrats and
republicans think alike both parties do
the federal courts and especially the
supreme court as a de facto branch of
the legislature in other words while
everyone may talk a big game about the
political neutrality of the supreme
court politicians of every stripe have
come to understand that in reality
whichever party appoints the most
justices wields the most power
particularly in a congress too divided
to do much of anything does this sound
kind of undemocratic well that may have
been the original point at the new york
ratifying convention for the
constitution hamilton himself said that
there are few positions more
demonstrable than that there should be
in every republic some permanent body to
correct the prejudices check the
interpret passions and regulate the
fluctuations of a popular assembly this
is basically like fancy colonial talk
for a rather chilling argument that we
need special appointed people to protect
us from our literal democracy on side
note uh classic greek philosopher plato
would largely agree on this or as
chamerinski puts it the primary reason
for having a supreme court then is to
enforce the constitution against the
will of the majority this seems true in
the expected decision ruling against roe
v wade which 64 of the country wants to
see upheld you may be thinking well then
we should change the constitution but
this was by design
made very very very difficult to do so
in a lot of ways we're all still
operating by a playbook written by slave
owners in the late 1700s as chimerinski
adds why should a society generally
committed to majority rule choose to be
governed by a document that is very
difficult to change and we've only
grazed the tip of the iceberg if you dig
deeper you'll find a history of the
court supporting things like eugenics
japanese internment camps severely
limiting free speech in times of war and
so on so is the supreme court beyond
fixing there are senators and
representatives who have proposed
changes such as expanding the court
imposing term limits and other measures
to curb the massive power currently
afforded to every supreme court justice
of course with the filibuster still in
place putting any of these changes in
motion is basically impossible and all
of these measures seem like
insurmountably uphill battles but if the
court continues to make unpopular
decisions maybe it'll finally spur the
kind of backlash they've been dreading
since 1787. so you're telling me there's
a chance
but what do you guys think are the nine
perfect strangers not so perfect after
all or should we give them more credit
for legislating with less than ideal
guidance from the founding fathers let
us know in the comments thanks to our
patrons for all your support and don't
forget to check out all our fun new
patreon perks bang that subscribe button
like it's your favorite gavel and don't
forget to ring that bell and as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
specifically what is called textualism
text textual textual oh my god
textualism it's happening oh no it's
happening